je peux vous ce qu'on a une caméra sur
Maya ok voilà mayalo qui est au taquet
et voilà voilà il faut que la France
sache la concentration de mamloqué avant
l'émission On n'est pas bien paisible
à la fraîche
contracté du gland gagner autant
d'argent ça fait péter les plombs et
l'autre
ça me trouve cette question en français
le rêve américain c'est au contraire nos
enfants les enfants les enfants à
l'école on envoie nos enfants à l'école
pourquoi
pourquoi on dit aux enfants il faut que
tu travailles bien l'école que tu es un
super boulot et pourquoi elle refuse
d'être payée par Amazon dans ce long
message blanche Gardin explique pourquoi
elle dit non à l'émission lol qui Rita
diffusé sur la plateforme vidéo du géant
américain l'humoriste explique être gêné
de gagner 200000 € pour 8h de tournage
surtout venant d'une entreprise qui je
cite ne paye pas ses impôts en France ou
encore détruit des emplois c'est une
problématique en France en France on ne
dit pas combien on gagne moi en
Angleterre c'était affiché tout le monde
savait combien les personnes guerrier
aux États-Unis bon je sais pas voilà
donc vous trouvez que les Français ont
un problème avec ça avec la réussite ou
avec l'argent avec la jalousie avec la
jalousie vous vous dites quoi
mais vous avez vécu du tout budget
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est avant toi et moi 4 étoiles pour la
suite de la folie viens on monte un
empire il dévoile mes recettes c'est
pour faire des lions mis avec Mamie tête
à tête y a une belle alchimie je me
trouve plutôt normal je dis je suis pas
belle pas l'aide je me suis trouvé
toujours dans la moyenne et je fais un
métier où souvent l'apparence est très
importante surtout pour une femme quand
j'ai commencé ce métier pour jouer les
jeunes filles j'aurais des jeunes
première c'est-à-dire des rôles très
très il faut être jolie il faut être
gracieux et j'étais pas tout ça
vous oui
ce garçon il est charmant bah maman elle
est née en 37 donc je sais pas
tu es méchant et je me disais bon
pourquoi pourquoi il y a des garçons qui
ont pas des physiques terribles et qui
jouent et pourquoi ce serait pas la même
chose pour les filles voilà pour moi il
y avait un différence de traitement
donc je me suis dit je vais devenir
vedette
je vais devenir vedette parce qu'il y a
pas de raison que je le devienne pas
très fort
en regarder ce jeune homme dont elle a
oublié le prénom aussi donc comme ça je
vous
rendsimer on va pas se marcher dessus et
du coup la note en plus
ma propre maman qui est probablement
devant le téléviseur était dans le même
lycée que vous mais c'est pas
[Applaudissements]
ah le lycée Vaugelas Chambéry d'accord
ok vous y avez laissé de bons souvenirs
la légalisation du mariage homosexuel
était une promesse de campagne du
candidat Hollande en 2012 le projet de
loi a été présenté à l'automne par
Christiane tobira ministre de la Justice
le député Erwan Binet en était le
rapporteur nous nous attendions à une
opposition parlementaire nous attendions
pas à une opposition si massive dans la
rue les opposants au mariage homosexuel
se regroupent sous le nom de manifs pour
tous pour dénoncer un texte qui serait
selon eux préjudiciable aux enfants
vous avez le temps de vous occuper de
votre fils très peu trop peu
il me dit en tout cas vous avez
culpabilisé enfin je pourrais vous
retourner le compliment mais il y a
toujours un moment où on travaille trop
oui
et là je me tais en fait salut à la
maison contrairement au pack ce qui
existe depuis 99 le mariage ouvre le
droit à une des figures du mouvement et
l'humoriste frigides barjot c'est le
mariage au monde qui enlève le mariage
civil tel qu'il était prévu entre hommes
et femmes depuis la nuit des temps le 23
avril 2013 le texte est adopté un mois
plus tard le premier mariage homosexuel
et célébré à Montpellier
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est pas mal
incroyable Camille tu sais ce qu'il faut
faire quand tu touches une méduse
pour éviter les piqûres
c'est cueilleur qu'on vous montrait hier
dans le 13h qui ramasse des champignons
et bien après vérification attention ce
qu'on a vu dans le reportage hier ce
sont de fausses morilles que l'on
appelle des giromites c'est très
ressemblant vous le voyez à droite les
morilles à gauche ces fausses morilles
les giromites il ne faut absolument pas
les consommer elles sont classifiées
comme toxiques et parfois même mortels
ne les consommez pas donc surtout
attention parce que les chenilles c'est
vénéneux
urticaire c'est urticaire attention
dites-moi Elodie j'ai l'impression que
vous avez vraiment envie de me faire
pipi
le mystère ministère de la Défense qui a
de son côté diffusé cette semaine un
film épique pour inciter les Russes à
suivre leur vocation
[Musique]
vraiment comme ça que vous rêviez de
défendre votre patrie nous sommes tous
des mentalistes alors c'est ce que j'ai
découvert en fait ce que vous avez
découvert un mentaliste c'est quelqu'un
qui a un cerveau et qui s'en sert et
j'ai fait des longues recherches et on a
tous un cerveau donc on n'est pas censé
je sais pas non mais le mentalisme
grandissant on se demande si c'est des
magiciens des voyants c'est pas tout à
fait là c'est pas du tout l'autre le
mentaliste c'est la subtile frontière
entre les deux ça s'appelle
l'escroquerie
c'est vraiment à ça que sert votre force
un spot qui se termine comme ça
[Musique]
vous êtes des hommes
trouvez-le